the favorite of a gajillion like little
kids that that obviously registers with
you right let it yeah I don't know what
it is about little kids but for some
reason they always love the music yeah
yeah well in the new album just fire
fire fire fire thank you all the way
around and we get to see like your
emotional life which is very cool the
ups and downs rollercoasters of emotions
that you've been going through you've
said that a lot of the album stems from
anxiety that you felt like you know
becoming famous the kind of life that
you lead when did you start feeling that
it was that something you started
feeling early on or that recent yeah I
mean it no no I was only I think only in
my blood was kind of focused on anxiety
but it was something I kind of extorted
experiencing about a couple years ago
and before that heard lots about it's a
very confusing thing for somebody who
has never experienced it to understand
what it means because it's different for
every person but for me it was about
creating a song that was vulnerable
because I realized I realized that music
is one of the most intimate things on
earth like it's so personal I don't
think about me listening to music is
yeah listen to it with my friends and I
go to shows and stuff but 90% of the
time it's me with headphones in you know
at the gym or whatever and I wanted to
create a song that was that had that
personal intimate thing for people who
needed it you know yeah and and the kind
of your fans look to you now in a way
for for guidance right like they sure in
your music and also and just kind of the
things that you say so how do you feel
being that's sort of representative for
people I think great I think I think one
thing that I I did a lot as I was
growing up and will kind of always live
by as I get older is that as long as
you're being truthful you can't really
be wrong it you know you can't really it
can't be you can be wrong but I'm saying
is like it's never bad to be truthful
and authentic and as long as I know what
I'm saying to my fans is what I would
say to my friends I'm happy because
that's the authentic opinion of what I
have and
and so the fact that they they know that
it's genuinely me when I'm tweeting and
it's genuinely me when they see me on
the street I think is what makes them
think know that they can trust me yeah
now opening yourself up emotionally even
if it's in the meeting that you love
like as a songwriter that musician can
be a scary thing what is your biggest
fear I don't know there's a few I think
fear of failure always is something
looming in the background but deep water
I think my biggest fear would be like to
fall off the back of a cruise ship or
something yeah well you guys take your
boots off when you go swimming yeah
maybe a better swimmer yeah you know you
have been saying that you want to be the
best male singer in the world I've said
that before how is that coming along
here you know I don't think I'll ever be
there that's a good goal to have I think
and for me yeah well always went out
when I first started and now I think
what I'm always thinking about is focus
on what's at hand which is making which
is playing guitar making music and
connecting with people and singing and
then the rest will come the rest will
happen around you and don't stress about
that because what is at hand is is music
and singing so yeah I practice a lot
yeah well given all the pressure that
you've you've got on your back is that
sort of goal something that is like
added pressure for you or is that
something some motivator for you oh
that's a motivator yeah I'm just
motivated to get better as I get older
and and take leaps instead of steps and
I think yeah hmm it's been fun following
your adventures like around the world
especially in the last few years how
everything's been ramping up but we have
seen younger artists like Sam Smith and
Adele kind of have issues with their
vocal cords with such a heavy schedule
is that something that you're concerned
about any point time yeah I mean it's
it's really hard sometimes you need to
know it's hard as an artist some not
push yourself because it's so hard not
to the whole world is cheering you on
and some days when you feel your most
exhausted you want to still get on the
stage and I think something you worry
about but you just it's a lot there's a
lot that comes goes into having vocal
problems you know you just have to be
really aware of that's
take rest sleep you know okay don't push
yourself too hard when I read that you
had been working with Teddy Geiger on
the album I was celebrating a bit teddy
I think is a bit of an unsung hero in
music super talented great writer when
it got out that you had been thinking oh
maybe I won't use as many pronouns in my
music after working with Teddy media
kind of picked up on it and we're like
oh yeah and that wasn't even a conscious
conscious decision it was just a natural
thing and I think you know media picking
up on that was looking into it a lot but
working with Teddy she's always been one
of my favorite people of all time we
immediately had a connection when I
first sang stitches and then you know as
she was going through one of the biggest
things the biggest thing to ever happen
in her life I was also making the
biggest album in my life and so together
we had this super kinetic emotional time
you know and I think I owe a lot of
being able to dig deep into myself to
Teddy because I was watching her go
through this really big change and kind
of you know how that was and it was it
was insane I always tell the story and
they and I feel like I talk about a lot
but for people who are confused about
transgender if they had a best friend
who that who was going through that
there was this one moment and it takes a
couple weeks to kind of get used to that
using the right pronoun as it should
normally it takes at some time and there
was one moment where I referred to Teddy
as she for the first time and it was a
natural thing I didn't think about it
for the first time it was just kind of
flew out and she turned around and she
looked at me and she had the most
genuine look of just her whole body was
full of happiness and I mean it if any
if everybody could experience one of
their best friends being that happy
because of that they would have no
questions there would no longer be
questions about it all and it would make
sense to everybody but it's hard too
hard for everyone to experience that